if you're a fan of power-hungry murder
teens and apple loving death gods then
you'll probably enjoy death note which
is about both those things and is
reportedly coming to netflix I'm Kate
and this is your heart attack inducing
news update the live-action film
adaptation of the hugely popular manga
and anime series death note is
apparently on the move it has been
reported that the film is on the verge
of shifting production from its current
home at Warner to Netflix according to
the wrap the streaming giant is in
negotiations to pick up the project the
site sources claim that the movie was
nearing the start of filming when Warner
decided not to move ahead however
instead of simply dropping it Warren
agreed to let director Adam Wingard take
the project elsewhere it is reported
that netflix have offered a firm
commitment to make the film and it is
expected that the deal will go through
in October last year it was reported
that nat wolff best known for the hit
teen drama The Fault in Our Stars have
been cast as the lead in death note the
series tells the story of a high school
student named light who comes into
possession of a supernatural notebook
that allows him to kill anyone whose
name he writes into it light sets out to
rid the world of evil but finds himself
relentlessly pursued by a legendary
police detective a you a Death Note fan
are you excited for the live-action film
let me know in the comments or come and
find me on Twitter I'm at how not to
draw thanks for watching and for all
your gaming and entertainment news keep
it gamespot